in addition to the mass mandate clark
county is renewing its focus on getting
everybody vaccinated this weekend they
brainstorm more and more ways to get
shots in arms
kate houston breaking down how the
mandate impacted vaccination rates and
some potential opportunities for clinics
yes bryan clark county chairwoman
marilyn kirkpatrick says this is an all
hands on deck situation
given the rise in cases and the fast
spreading delta variant
commissioners are trying to get creative
in where they provide additional clinics
right now they're really trying to reach
18 to 40 year olds
which kirkpatrick says have taken the
brunt of the delta variant
they're also trying to find ideal clinic
hours for those who work 12 to 14 hours
a day
many days a week kirkpatrick says there
could be more clinics in malls
car washes job sites and hard hit zip
codes
over the weekend there was a line at the
galleria mall vaccination clinic which
kirkpatrick says was encouraging
some think the mask mandate could
influence even more people to get the
vaccine
it definitely should encourage people to
go back and get vaccinated
especially because i know a lot of
people were feeling good about not
having to wear a mask you know
everything was lifted
so that little bit of freedom that we
had you know is being taken away so i'm
pretty sure people are going to start
getting more
vaccinated and stuff clark county hopes
more people can get the vaccine in the
next few weeks ahead of the new school
year and flu season
kirkpatrick says the delta variant and
the common cold have similar symptoms
and they don't want any further spread
and as students prepare to head back to
class the health district is offering
mandatory vaccines and the covenant 19
vaccine at schools across the valley
for a complete list you can head to our
website 8newsnow.com